from the from the US Sun ready for nuke
Armageddon inside Doomsday Bunkers
designed by U.S government to withstand
nuclear apocalypse and restart America
in case of Wipeout
they say the U.S government built
several doomsday nuclear look at these
pictures why are they why would they
even show anybody this is Cheyenne
Mountain can withstand a 30 Megaton
nuclear bomb oh okay so you mean it
can't withstand the the Satan II missile
what's the point thanks for telling us I
gotta tell you I see these videos I see
these photos these stories about Mount
weather am I really supposed to believe
that Raven Rock Mount weather these
facilities are the legitimate facilities
for our government when we all know they
exist and 30 megatons is that it come on
sarbama was a hundred at full capacity
not that they're going to get a bomber
over it you know but taking on
underground four to five facilities 90s
you have to tremendously good accuracy I
grew up in Lincoln Nebraska 60 miles
from Offutt Air Force Base Strategic Air
Command uh headquarters you know one of
the top nuclear targets I remember
reading one day that the the uh I the
the accuracy of Russian Soviet missiles
was about 50 miles although that's great
they're going to aim it off and they're
going to hit me in Lincoln they're not
that accurate now that's proved a lot
our weapons have improved a lot but when
was the last time we even detonated a
nuclear weapon it's been about 30 years
we got rid of underground nuclear
testing so for a nuclear weapon to go
and take out something like Mount
weather it'd have to be very very
accurate weapon would have to have you
know its full yield but why and they're
probably not going to have that accuracy
so I think they will survive in Mountain
West no I'm saying they've got to have
other bunkers we don't know but they
have a lot of them their site are
there's quite a few in Pennsylvania
again you guys are kind of in a bad
place for nuclear weapons here I I
disagree David you got the Pentagon you
got DC you got now weather you got
sidear I don't think they're not that
accurate so they're aiming at them they
could end up landing on you I think well
first before we get into the new stuff I
want to ask you about driving past Mount
weather they're doing construction there
oh a lot of it and I said that's above
ground and most of it's underground so I
can't imagine what's going on
underground so it's already been a huge
FEMA facility we gotta get some
reporting on this we got to send
somebody to go interview something to
get disappeared you mean slightly
request an interview
and the government is very secretive
especially about their other facilities
that they don't talk about that there's
no pictures of that there's no talk
about uh there's no talking about
there's a lot of underground facilities
that the United States has been
investing in there's a reason the
Pentagon has secret clandestine black
budgets there's a reason why so much
money is missing from the federal
coffers because a lot of times they're
spending it on a lot of top secret
projects that are underground facilities
that they have already implemented that
no one even knows about like black sites
yeah and black though well the black
sites are in Egypt and Poland and other
places around the world some torture
people but that's a different scenario
I'm interested in Mount weather it's
very close to where we are and so what
what's what's the gist of this can you
tell us the basic like what is it sure
it's an underground shelter uh FEMA
defends it on the surface and the
military troops will be there as well
but it's a place where congressmen will
go it's fairly close to DC so they can
whisk them off there and they've got
fantastic facilities they even have
media rooms so the congressman can
continue to you know transmit to their
constituents and you know not lose votes
if there's another election I guess but
they have fantastic facilities where
they'll stay alive and nothing is done
for the rest of us you know we're don't
even give us warning hey you might want
to do your own preparations things are
kind of bad oh no no that's just for
them the modern left mocks those who
would be prepared for even a rainy day
it's it's amazing we've got these these
hurricanes these floods but it is it is
a joke it's it's
it is common Urban culture to mock
Preppers to assume that anybody who's
prepared in any way is some lunatic
mountain man when you know I was in uh I
was in Arizona a couple years ago and I
was doing a toilet paper conflict
everyone's fighting over toilet paper I
go to a gas station and some lady you
know I say like how has it been out here
and she's like is this is the middle of
nowhere Arizona's like a weird little
rest stop and she's like oh we're good
we're Preppers so we've got like three
months worth of toilet paper already so
we haven't noticed anything and I
started laughing and I was like you know
what while they're all fighting in
Walmart over toilet paper they're making
fun of you for having it it's the
craziest thing yeah well the the image
of Preppers and preparedness has
improved a lot over the past couple
years this is partly covid-19 but it was
really less coveted 19 than things like
Portland and all the unrest that was
going on people saw how if people start
protesting start looting police cannot
stop it I'm not criticizing police there
just aren't many of them compared to
people if a lot of people start breaking
the law start looting start doing
whatever they they want to do you cannot
stop them so people have realized that
you know you really do need preparedness
people can get out of control can do
violence and you cannot put it down
there's not enough police or even
military folks to do that one of the
funniest things ever was when the
pandemic started and a bunch of liberals
were lining up outside of gun stores to
buy guns for the first time and the best
thing to emerge from it was the gun
store I think it was in California where
they were like the guy makes a video
saying stop complaining to me about why
you can't buy a gun you voted for this
you all voted for it people people come
to the gun store thinking they can buy a
gun and then walk out of the store with
and they can't they gotta come back
three days later and they're freaking
out like what why like there's a
pandemic there's no food I need I need
to protect myself well too bad you voted
for it that's why I like States like
West Virginia
conceal a constitutional carry you walk
in you got to fill out your federal
background check but uh you know the
first time you do it I think everyone
I've seen the first time they've tried
they've been held up a little bit for a
day or a couple days but then after that
it's like you walk in you can get it you
can carry it right out conceal it and
whatever and take care of yourself and
you can defend yourself so I feel like
New York City is going to be
man I don't even know I don't think any
movies any movie or any fiction has done
apocalypse justice as to what I think
would actually happen in a city like New
York in central Brooklyn where in the
first day when a collapse happens nobody
has any idea what's going on they have
food in their fridge it starts running
out they go and look around people are
confused by the second day all the
food's probably gone taken within a few
days anything that was perishable has
perished there's some canned goods left
and now people are really hungry and
really thirsty and looking around
wondering what's going on
So What by then the smart people have
all left and the people who aren't smart
and have been confused this whole time
what eat each other drink blood well
there is a much much bigger and better
awareness of preparedness in the US over
the past years I mean that's absolutely
clear we cannot keep up with the demand
we get people every day emailing us
asking for information wanting to join
and we just fall further and further
behind we can't meet the demand that's
why fortuit Ranch has started
franchising now we can't build enough to
keep up so we're franchising now so if
you that's kind of crazy you've got a
survival Community or if you've got a an
RV park you got a ranch and you think
hey I could have a nice survival
facility here you can now build one and
we will help you do it through our
franchisor bro because we can't keep up
we also can't keep up with hiring so
we're looking for more folks if an
interested in working on our staff are
the staff of a franchisee you know if
you want to contact fortifiedranch.com
at our website we're looking for more
people but we can't keep up with demand
but that's one of the point I wanted to
make is the other reason why
preparedness has had a bad image is is
that stupid show Doomsday Preppers which
made Preppers look like idiots when the
reason they did that is the first rule
of prepping is don't tell anyone you're
a prepper you keep it a secret you don't
want people to know hey I got a lot of
guns and food and ammo at my house if
there's a pandemic or the grids down
they're going to come to your house or
chickens either to bed yeah you keep
that confidential so no one is going to
go on a TV show and say hey I'm a
prepper here's all my preparations
here's what I've got they only had
idiots on that show that show really
hurt preparedness smart people are
Preppers it's insurance it's a life
insurance policy not to pay you if you
die but to keep you alive so our members
are very smart people they're electric
professionals yeah we got a lot of
former military we have some
intelligence officials but largely it's
business people and people who are smart
and educated and they don't talk about
it they keep it confidential but the
demand is growing growing growing and we
can't keep up so we're looking for more
wisdom of the crowd franchise how many
how many government officials do you
have contacting you for your services
and and guilty pleasure I really like
that show that you mentioned because it
was really fun to watch
um but not not strategic but but it was
fun to see uh well government officials
don't need us again they've got that I
mean even even at the state level you
know the state patrol provides
protection for the government in the
normal course of Duty and they'll do a
lot more when there's a collapse what
about government employees oh we have
government employees we have people from
Homeland Security from the Pentagon at
our West Virginia location does that
does that is it does it seem like
there's more of them more more people
work for the government than other
sectors no most of our members are some
business professionals is probably our
most common category we have a lot of
doctors now that's the other thing
covid-19 change for us as a medical
community really got hold of
preparedness wow we used to be it used
to be you know sometimes we would have
hard time getting doctors and we had
four doctors at 40 Ranch Colorado I
don't need four doctors there but a lot
of them have joined since the pandemic
you guys are franchising how does that
work how do you get involved with
someone that has space that wants to
become a franchisee oh if they got our
website there's information on it but
basically we're going to provide you the
training the operations manual help you
design your facility and make it
possible for you to be part of the 14th
Ranch system and you will be part of our
system because our system is again we're
a survival committee but we're also a
recreational facility so you can be a
member in West Virginia but you can go
to our lake property in Wisconsin you
come to a high mountain desert in Nevada
come to Texas and you know go to San
Antonio and the attractions down there
it's a vacation place too so you have a
home Fort where your stuff is and where
you try to get in a collapse but again
if you're if you're a West Virginia
member but you know you're doing the Tim
show out in California and the [ __ ] hits
a fan and you can't get back to West
Virginia you can go to Nevada and we'll
take care of you there and a franchise
would be the same way you're part of the
system so your members have the right to
you know they'd be home 40ing at your
place but they could use any of the 43rd
but if things get bad you got to go work
in the field oh absolutely our members
understand that you know it's a vacation
place you know come out shoot weapons
have fun and good times and bad times we
will work you very hard everyone will do
guard Duty and we got a lot of work to
do uh we'll be cutting down trees
building our walls improving our
defenses slaughtering animals we'll be
poaching massively I mean if you're a
deer near us when the [ __ ] hits the fan
we will be shooting you and making jerky
out of you so and then what about
expanding the territory and seizing the
land from the from the surrounding uh we
don't do that we are we're strictly uh
strictly a defensive motion we're an eye
on Steve Renee our CEO has been on your
shift several times and I know he's
pointed out we are not an offensive
militia we're an animal issue if there
are good militia groups don't get me
wrong but we are not one we don't do
anything offensive we defend our private
property in a collab but but let's let's
say we're now you know five years into a
collapse the surrounding homes have all
been abandoned you gotta have Scott
patrols go out and start looking for
seeing what's going on and you know they
I imagine you guys would not be
offensive but what if there's abandoned
land you need it for grazing or
expansion because now you got more
people are coming or you've signed on
more or Village members I suppose or
let's say it's even 15 20 years you're
gonna have more people more kids you're
gonna need to expand it's uh well I
actually haven't thought that through to
be honest with you but you know we're
hoping that uh the recovery would start
within a year or two if it's a really
bad pandemic and eventually we're hoping
that some Law and Order will return but
if not you know we'd have to deal with
whatever it is that's why all of our
Ranch Management over former military
officers and enlisted folks who have
good background and good judgment and
then our membership is this is a really
well educated good people so we've got a
core of people you know 100 plus people
at every location so we could do
whatever we need to do in a responsible
manner to survive and then to recover
after things improve two more questions
about the franchising one it's um it's
for profit the company's for-profit yes
um and then if someone opens up a
franchisee location are they doing all
the the hiring and taking all the
profits themselves or are you guys
supplying the funds for them to do
hiring and then you take a cut are there
a private business the only difference
is you know unlike a typical franchise
where you know your customers are kind
of your customers if you joined 40
grants you're part of the whole system
that's kind of a key Advantage we offer
is again you may not be able to get back
to your own fort you may want to
Vacation another location so members are
all in one system but it is your your
property your 14 Ranch location your
business you hire you fire you Superman
do you pay like a franchise licensing
fee or something a franchise fee to join
and then a percent of royalties like any
other franchise cool but then when the
apocalypse happens you have a network
correct and so I'd imagine if you know
one one location is starting to suffer
the other locations can provide
assistance uh we'll be uh would be up on
ham radio so we've got our frequencies
and times the day that you know at this
time and this night we're on this
frequency so we can connect so for
example back to the doctors we've got I
mean we've got like you know cancer
experts at some point Place we've got OB
GYN you know birthing doctors at another
but at night mainly use HF radio at
night with better bouncing off the
signal so at night you know the doctors
can confer so we can do that kind of in
terms of physical assistance during a
collapse no probably not a 1400 inch is
pretty much going to be on their own you
got to hunker down and there's probably
going to be no outside contact thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there